uh what world leader would you drink
with if you could you imagine Putin
so Putin doesn't drink much yeah
zielinski drinks more yeah also not much
of course he also would have been good
you would have been a [__] good one I
mean like I I go Hitler was a [__] like
he he drank wine with a with a cut with
a spoonful of sugar in it you never
drank what Churchill that's why hold on
that's my guy yeah you know that's my
guy right no I don't know that's okay
so he uh he did champagne you don't have
to tell me anything about Winston
Churchill he I found out about his daily
routine yeah so his daily routine was a
big breakfast cigar coffee eggs over you
egg sunny side up toast bacon sausage
tomato beans uh fruit orange juice soft
Scotch cigar in bed and he sit there for
three hours and he'd hold morning
breakfast and that's they'd come in and
he'd run through his day and then he'd
get in the bathtub for [__] an hour
and drink champagne and then he'd go to
lunch and have some Goose or whatever
the [__] they ate back then with more
champagne and then
and then and then I mean and then you
take a nap and like I love that so every
year on hit the day of his death things
January 24th I celebrate Winston
Churchill's Life by living the way he
did and so I have breakfast in bed with
a soft scotch and I just party all
[__] day that would be the guy to
drink with that would be the guy if you
could pick anyone to drink with he drank
every day throughout the day he lived
like 94. and was
one of the most heroic figures in human
history Never Never Surrender
I mean what a [__] badass thing you
know he taught he taught the Queen the
queen was like uh like a like a window
licking idiot right like she was she had
a third grade education so like her dad
dies and she's like 10 or 12 or whatever
the first thing they do is they pull her
out of school then I keep done learning
he's just gonna be the queen you gotta
know this is what you need to learn
don't make let people make eye contact
with you put your hand down like this
don't let people touch you so she like
she had like a really I saw the by the
way I didn't do this research I just
watched the crown okay and Winston
Churchill kind of taught her about world
politics and was they like coming and
she'd be like Winston what did we do in
Africa and he's like oh this is gonna be
a tough one and so yeah so but Winston
Churchill's the badass